nous déplacer ou pour produire des
richesses eh bien on en débat ce soir
avec jean marc jancovici vous êtes
ingénieur polytechnicien vous dirigez
carbone4 une société de conseil en
transition énergétique
vous présidez également un think tank
qui propose de décider pour nous libérer
de notre dépendance aux énergies
fossiles comme le pétrole le charbon ou
le gaz
dans votre dernier livre dormez
tranquilles jusqu'en 2100 vous nous
alerter sur notre méconnaissance des
problèmes énergétiques qui sont pourtant
le nerf de l'économie et de l'écologie
geneviève ferone creusez vous êtes l'une
des pionnières de la notation sociale et
environnementale des entreprises
aujourd'hui vous présidez un cabinet de
conseil sur les questions de transition
écologique
vous venez de publier le crépuscule
fossiles les énergies fossiles ont régné
sans partage pendant plus d'un siècle
dites vous mais la crise climatique et
énergétique nous oblige aujourd'hui à
imaginer une autre civilisation une
civilisation poste fossiles francis
duseux vous avez fait toute votre
carrière professionnelle dont la société
pétrolière américaine exxon mobil ça ait
duré jusqu'à 40 ans jusqu'à devenir en
2006 le pdg d'esso pour la france depuis
le 1er janvier 2015 vous présidez
l'union française des industries
pétrolières l'ufip
l'organisation professionnelle qui
regroupe les sociétés pétrolières de
notre pays
philippe bihouix vous êtes ingénieur
spécialiste des ressources non
renouvelables vous êtes l'auteur de quel
futur pour les métaux et plus récemment
de l'âge des low tech les basses
technologies les seuls qui soient
soutenables à votre avis
non seulement il va falloir accepter
d'avoir des produits un peu moins
performant un peu moins léger un peu
moins esthétique mais les héros de
demain d'après vous ce seront les
paysans les chiffonniers les cordonniers
les mécaniciens les menuisiers les
réparateurs d'électronique et
d'électroménager ou d'informatique voilà
les métiers d'avenir
alix mazouni
mazouni par dont vous êtes responsables
des politiques internationales du réseau
action climat qui rassemble seize
associations environnementales
françaises
luttant contre les changements
climatiques la coop 21 et votre huitième
conférence internationale sur le climat
vous y défendent et le recours massif
aux énergies renouvelables mais pas le
nucléaire
pascal canfin ancien ministre du
développement du gouvernement de jean
marc ayrault ancien député européen
europe ecologie les verts vous êtes
conseiller climat du world resources
institute c'est l'un des think tanks les
plus influents du monde sur les
questions environnementales et vous
venez d'être nommé directeur général de
l'organisation écologiste wwf
le world wild fund pour la france vous
prendrez vos fonctions début janvier
et puis vous venez de publier enfin il
ya quelques mois déjà mais c'est un gros
succès de librairie climat 30 questions
pour comprendre la conférence de paris
alors la conférence de paris elle se
tient en ce moment même et au coeur des
négociations évidemment il y as en
filigrane je dis bien en filigrane la
question de l'énergie fois nous y sommes
au pied du mur selon certains les 150
chefs d'état et de gouvernement seront
ils à la hauteur des espoirs placés en
eux c'est la photo de famille de cette
coop 21 hors norme
tellement de chef de délégation que sur
la photo toute entière
on peine à les distinguer nous sommes au
bord d'un suicide
je crois que presque tous les dirigeants
qui participent à la coop 21 à paris
sont conscients de cette situation pour
rester sous la barre des deux degrés de
réchauffement
il faudra réduire de 70 % les émissions
mondiales de gaz à effet de serre d'ici
je vous le dis franchement les bons
sentiments
les déclarations d'intention ne
suffiront pas nous sommes au bord d'un
point de rupture pollution de l'air des
fleuves sécheresse
catastrophes en tous genres pour éviter
que ces images se multiplient les
acteurs de la coop 21 s'engagent plus ou
moins les etats unis reconnaissent leur
rôle dans la création du réchauffement
climatique et nous assumons notre
responsabilité pour régler ce problème
si nous continuons sur le chemin tracé
par le capitalisme mondial l'humanité
est condamné à disparaître chose comme
stowe ce que je peux vous dire c'est
qu'il est tout à fait possible de monier
croissance économique de 8 heures et
protection de la nature
héros de fable victor hugo a dit c'est
pas ça des difficultés extrêmes
il faut trouver des solutions extrêmes
oui de mouches sont les a pas besoin
d'aller vers des sources d'énergie qui
sont encore moins cher quand il joue au
carbone utilisons aujourd'hui nous
devons avoir une énergie fiable
je pense que nous regarderons notre
journée d'aujourd'hui comme une étape
importante dans cette mission mais
lorsqu'on est directeur d'abord pour
dire que dans la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique la question
centrale c'est la question de l'énergie
que nous utilisons pascal canfin
il ya deux sujets majeurs et à la
question géopolitique un des sujets
majeurs de paris c'est quelle relation
quelle place pour les pays émergents qui
aujourd'hui sont exclus de toutes
obligations qui vont en prendre à paris
mais lesquels les mêmes que les nôtres
ou d'autres le deuxième essai des
obligations concernent notamment
l'énergie exactement est le deuxième
sujet c'est évidemment l'énergie qui est
responsable des deux tiers à peu près
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
dans le monde donc on est d'accord c'est
l'énergie tout le monde est d'accord sur
cette question parce qu'elle confère la
dce et les deux tiers du problème
donc c'est pas tout le problème mais
enfin on peut difficilement résoudre le
problème sans son voile à l'énergie
france et bien sûr
je reconnais que le pétrole et le gaz
est une partie du problème mais on ne
peut pas se passer de ces énergies
pendant les 50 ans qui viennent
je crois qu'il ya là comme un t1 une
prise de conscience du grand public de
tous les industriels
donc je crois qu'il ya put climato
sceptiques chez les pétroliers mais ceci
dit faut tenir compte des réalités la
demande des gens c'est disposer sécurité
d'approvisionnement et disposer d'une
énergie la moins chère possible
je crois qu'une dame le disais dans
votre introduction le challenge s'est
trouvé des énergies renouvelables qui
soit pas cher en base et les besoins
c'est quoi le problème principal pour
moi c'est la démographie
on a sept milliards d'habitants en 2050
on sera à 9.5 peut-être à 11 11
milliards en 2100 les gens ont besoin
d'électricité sa première demande
ensuite de voiture donc on a des
problèmes immenses devant nous devons la
taille des besoins en énergie de cette
planète si sûr que pour nous l'enjeu
principal de la coop 21 c'est bien
d'enclencher d'accompagner et
d'accélérer la transition énergétique
mondiale dont on a besoin d'ailleurs
finalement un des enjeux de la co 21
sait aussi comment on va faire pour
accompagner en solidarité en fait la
transition énergétique des pays les plus
pauvres parce que doit s'appliquer à
tout le monde l'idée c'est pas d'aller
construire des centrales à charbon en
afrique et nous de développer les
renouvelables c'est que tout le monde
développent la même transition
énergétique et pour nous c'est clair que
l'aide l'avenir il est dans les énergies
renouvelables
d'ailleurs ce n'est pas l'avenir c'est
déjà une réalité aujourd'hui elles sont
en train de se développer massivement
n'a jamais eu autant d'investissements
plus que dans toutes les autres
la capacité installée aujourd'hui
électrique
elle est principalement renouvelable
chaque année donc il ya énormément de
progrès de ce côté là aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs il ya vous l'avez pas fait
passer mais il ya six ans mère ce qui
représente je crois plus de 600 millions
d'habitants le monde qui viennent de
s'engager en disant nous d'ici à 2050 on
sera 100% renouvelable
c'est un message extrêmement fort c'est
600 millions d'habitants dans le monde
leurs élus locaux qui sont en train de
me dire que ils vont tout mettre en
oeuvre donc si ces personnes à s'engage
c'est pas juste pour faire voilà c'est
pas par miracle c'est parce que
effectivement une le potentiel est là on
est en train de le développer et que
maintenant la dernière chose à faire je
pense c'est d'arrêter de subventionner
les énergies fossiles
parce que ça c'est le pétrole le gaz le
charbon et 80 les 3a les trois gros
problème il faut arrêter de
subventionner parce que tant qu'on les
subventionnent effectivement
rennes cette transition énergétique
philippe bihouix alors on va parler
d'énergie mais effectivement c'est faut
pas oublier le dernier tiers parce qu'il
ya quand même toute la question des
pratiques agricoles notamment la
quantité de viande qu'on mange avec les
le méthane et puis la déforestation
changement d'usagé des sols les soldes
c'est un un endroit où on stocke
massivement du carbone aujourd'hui donc
il ya quand même aussi ces deux sujets
là sur l'énergie je partage un ensemble
de choses qui ont été dites simplement
alors il ya des engagements
effectivement sur le 100 % renouvelable
en 2050 d'un certain nombre de pays etc
alors il faut juste avoir en tête que
l'on pourra faire 100% de renault va
peut-être pour les îles tuvalu peut-être
pour un certain nombre de groupes de
pays mais sûrement pas pour l'ensemble
de la planète et encore moins s'il faut
assurer de la croissance démographique
et de la croissance de consommation
derrière tout simplement parce que déjà
notre niveau actuel en valeur absolue
n'est pas soutenable
il est passé aux tables cette gabegie
énergétique et de matières premières
pourquoi parce que oui on a aussi mille
fois je crois la quantité de soleil qui
nous tombe dessus par rapport à l'an
modeste besoin d'humanité à date
simplement il faut des quantités
importantes de ressources métalliques
pour converti capter convertir stocker
et transporter ses énergies et tout ça
ça va être très compliqué mais on n'en
parlerait total on se demandera s'il y
aura assez d'énergie pour tout le monde
geneviève ferone cause est alors moins
nager jeu des zooms un petit peu et puis
je voudrais je voudrais juste mentionné
qu'on a juste un sujet de civilisation
parce que cette civilisation dans
laquelle on est tous embarqués lors on
est tous embarqués c'est à dire 7
milliards un peu plus de sept milliards
de personnes
quand je dis tous c'est vraiment tous et
on est tous embarqués sur une
civilisation qui s'est bâtie sur le
primat des énergies fossiles et donc
avec des conséquences géopolitiques
économiques politiques considérables
donc aujourd'hui on parle de la question
de l'énergie mais c'est vrai que changer
d'énergie ça vaudra peut-être aussi dire
changer embarqué dans une autre
civilisation alors elle sera post facile
je sais pas trop quel sont les mots et
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que nous
projettons dans ce poste facile pour
certains ça peut être quelque chose qui
comme on va peut-être pas y arriver ou
que la transition va être longue
douloureuse peut-être source d'inégalité
vers quoi allons-nous
ou alors est-ce que cette transition si
on écoute les chefs d'état qui sont tous
la main sur le coeur c'est pas la
première fois qu'ils sont la main sur le
coeur
on les a déjà vus sur la photo la main
sur le coeur enfin en tous les cas là je
pense qu'ils ont peut-être senti qu'ils
étaient aussi poussés par leur société
civile par leurs habitants
ils sont aussi poussé par les
entreprises et les banques qui réclament
des nouvelles règles du jeu
donc est-ce qu'on va embarquer dans un
nouveau récit et ce sera peut-être une
civilisation plus pacifique plus
démocratique avec des fondamentaux plus
égalitaire donc on voit qu'on est à
l'articulation voilà il ya une
intersection il ya deux récits possible
et bien sûr les énergies sont tous sont
une partie structurantes de ce récit
alors justement vous l'avez dit on
consomme pas tous autant d'énergie et on
n'en voit pas tous autant de gaz à effet
de serre dans l'atmosphère
évidemment je propose un petit panorama
des de nos émissions de gaz carbonique
vous allez voir ce long selon les
continents c'est pas tout à fait la même
chose sur notre planète nous n'émettons
pas tous la même quantité de gaz
carbonique
un américain en rejettent 16 tonnes par
an un chinois 7,2 un européen 6,8 et un
africain
une petite tonnes seulement si
l'américain polluent le plus c'est parce
qu'il est riche
l'an dernier il a pu dépenser 51500 2
euros ils achètent des produits dont le
transport et le stockage émettent du co2
et surtout ils consomment beaucoup de
pétrole pour faire rouler automobiles et
camions ce qui représente 40 % de ses
émissions
si le chinois et le deuxième pollueur de
notre liste ce n'est pas parce qu'il est
riche mais parce qu'il fait tourner des
usines qui produisent pour le monde
entier
des quantités colossales de charbon sont
engloutis en énergie ce qui représente
72% de ses émissions de co2 l'européen
lui aimait peu de carbone d'abord parce
qu'une part importante de son industrie
a été délocalisée en asie ensuite parce
qu'il utilise l'énergie nucléaire et des
énergies renouvelables qui ne rejette
pas de co2 elle compte pour 25% dans sa
consommation d'énergie totale
la france elle est carrément championne
avec 41 % de son énergie qui vient du
nucléaire
celui qui pollue le moins c'est
finalement l'africain en 2013 il n'avait
que 942 euros à dépenser dans l'année il
consomme donc très peu d'énergie est né
mais quasiment aucun gaz carbonique
si on veut réduire de 70% nos émissions
de gaz à effet de serre d'ici 2050 c'est
le le projet a priori pour tenir en
dessous des 2 degrés d'augmentation à la
fin du siècle
ce que ce dont tout le monde rêve est
évidemment pas forcément il va falloir
changer tout ça alors le charbon par
exemple vous rappelez dans votre livre
je crois qu'il ya encore vingt mille
centrales à charbon dans le monde
il ya des pays comme l'afrique du sud 90
% de leurs ressources de leur
consommation d'énergie c'est le charbon
je crois que c'est la même chose à peu
près en inde
qu'est ce qu'on va faire du jour au
lendemain on leur dit enfin d'ici on va
dire 2030 on va leur dire faut fermer
tout ça et on le remplace par quoi
d'abord c'est une bonne nouvelle qu'on
parle du charbon parce que le charbon a
été très peu présent dans les débats sur
le changement climatique en france parce
que les caméras de télévision n'ont pas
de centrales à charbon a montré en
france y en a pas beaucoup
il faut savoir que le charbon c'est 40%
de l'électricité mondiale entre le
nucléaire c'est 13% et
l'hydroélectricité à peu près la même
chose
les seules centrales à charbon dans le
monde font 20% des émissions mondiales
de gaz à effet de serre pour donner une
image
en face les voitures mondiales ces 5%
les camions mondiaux c'est 5% fin peu
moins donc les centrales à charbon sont
un vrai sujet est toujours pour finir
là-dessus centrales électriques 1
aujourd'hui il y a trente fois plus de
centrales à charbon dans le monde que
nous avons des réacteurs nucléaires en
france 30 fois plus et si on veut être
sérieux sur les 2 degrés il faut que
toutes ses centrales à charbon
disparaissent dans les 30 ans qui
viennent
alors le charbon est une énergie
domestique c'est une énergie qui
voyagent peu un gros 10% du charbon dans
le monde franchit une frontière entre le
pays qu'ils extraient et le pays qu'ils
consomment et 90% du charbon dans le
monde est détenu par huit pays seulement
ça veut dire quelque chose de très
simple cette affaire ça veut dire que le
problème est dans les mains des états
qui consomment le charbon est pas dans
les mains des autres ça veut dire que
pour qu'on leur demande d'arrêter de
consommer du charbon il va falloir payer
parce que si vous êtes à la place de
quelqu'un qui a du charbon et quand vous
demande de préserver un bien mondial
contre l'abandon d'un tract est chez
vous faut payer même les américains
parce que les américains font partie de
ces pays
oui mais les premiers détenteurs de
centrales à charbon dans le monde
maintenant c'est les chinois alors les
américains passerait bien payé pour
remettre du reste ils sont en train de
le faire à cause de quelque chose de
tout à fait inattendu c'est que chez eux
le gaz est en train de chasser le
charbon dans la production électrique
tout simplement parce que ils ont lu
récemment des grandes quantités de gaz à
bas prix et la surproduction gaz en gros
donc le prix du gaz s'est effondré
aujourd'hui la meilleure manière de
produire de l'électricité pas cher aux
états unis célia c'est pour ça que c'est
une des explications pas la seule mais à
la baisse des émissions américaines donc
ça doit rien appris de vertu et tout au
fait qu' ils ont fait des trous et
qu'ils ont sortis du gaz donc les
chinois les indiens aussi le charbon
l'afrique du sud avec l'allemagne et ces
deux pays très différent parce que la
chine est un pays dirigé l'inde un peu
moins l'inde est une démocratie on
connaît un peu la démocratie on allait
chez nous donc on voit peu à quoi ça
ressemble
la chine n'est pas une démocratie ça a
des avantages et des inconvénients mais
du coup l'équation se présente pas de la
même manière et je voudrais aussi comme
je le disais tout à l'heure tempérer un
peu l'optimisme
moi j'adore quand on prend des
engagements qui vont dans le sens de ce
dont j'ai envie parce que bon c'est
quand même plutôt sympa on a vraiment
envie d'y croire
enfin quiconque a entendu des promesses
électorales égrainé se dit que quand on
en fait une
au surplus pas chez soi collective dans
ce genre d'enceinte faut être un tout
petit peu prudent sur la signification
réelle de cet engagement à qui vous
faites allusion à ce qui se passe au kop
oui un exercice cruel un peu cruel
auxquels je me suis livrée est du reste
que je détaille dans mon livre c'est que
j'ai regardé les pays qui avaient
ratifié kyoto et ceux qui ne l'avaient
pas ratifié et j'ai regardé si
l'évolution sur le contenu en co2
l'économie était différent et la réponse
très cruel c'est qui a pas de différence
c'est à dire que les choses se sont
passées de la même manière selon que les
états aient ratifié ou pas kyoto il ya
quinze ans ce qui veut dire c'est une
bonne et mauvaise nouvelle la mauvaise
nouvelle c'est que ce qui se passe à la
coop
si ça se passe mal c'est peut-être pas
très grave parce que c'est pas là que ça
se passe
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il ya des
déterminants de l'action qui sont
ailleurs et qui aujourd'hui sont en
train de se mettre en place et d'une
manière qui à mon avis n'est pas
réversible
alors restons sur le charbon un instant
comment on remplace ces quantités
phénoménales de charbon aujourd'hui
qu'ils sont consommés dans le monde et
qui émettent du gaz à effet de serre la
bonne nouvelle c'est que cette
révolution
la transformation du charbon elle
parlait renouvelables est en train
d'arriver
c'est à dire que pour la première fois
dans toute l'histoire en 2013 donc
c'était il ya deux ans c'est tout
nouveau tout le monde ne sait pas encore
et c'est pas perçu la première fois
depuis mai dans toute l'histoire les
renouvelables font plus de la moitié des
nouvelles capacités qui sont installés
dans le monde pour produire de
l'électricité
donc ça veut dire que cette
transformation ce point de bascule il a
eu en 2013
les renouvelables l'éolien les on nous a
même pas nier le panier de renouvela
dans sa diversité vous est ce que
racontait le nucléaire dans leur nous on
n'a pas le norbert dans le renouvelable
c'est le renouvelable du caire et donc
les déchets sont durables et inversent
leurs nuls et donc les maths ans et 58 %
en 2014
donc voyez on a on franchit je sais pas
combien ce sera en 2015 peut-être 65% et
on voit bien que pour les nouvelles
capacités qui sont installés on tend
vers un avenir qu'ils soient à 80 90 %
renouvelable tout simplement parce que
contrairement peut-être est-ce que jean
marc jancovici viens de dire il n'y a
pas d'enjeu de compétitivité le coup
aujourd'hui il est de plus en plus
faible pour les renouvelables et il est
quasiment moins cher maintenant que le
charbon je vous donne un exemple vous
pariez l'afrique du sud l'afrique du sud
c'est là une cei qui dirige l'afrique du
sud la ncc liés aux syndicats parmi les
syndicats il est très gros syndicat
charbonnier donc c'est parti de nelson
mandela c'est impossible politiquement
pour le parti de nelson mandela de dire
j'arrête le charbon donc qu'est ce
qu'ils font ils disent bah écoutez moi
je fais des enchères et que le meilleur
gagne
il vient la quasi-totalité des enchères
qui ont été faites en afrique du sud
récemment qui a gagné pas le charbon
ce sont les renouvelables parce que
c'est en train de devenir les moins
chers et je veux donner une autre source
qui est deutsche bank qui est pas
vraiment une officine écologistes
décroissante radical deutsche bank une
des plus grandes banques du monde qui
dit d'ores et déjà aujourd'hui dans plus
de la moitié des marchés du monde
les renouvelables sont moins chers que
le fossile équivalent et notamment que
le charbon pour produire de
l'électricité
donc cette révolution elle est en train
d'arriver c'est pour ça que je ne crois
pas du tout on est dans les 50
prochaines années encore besoin du
fossile tout simplement parce que on est
en train de faire la transition
tout l'enjeu c'est d'accélérer c'est
pour ça qu'on a besoin d'un accord est
là qu on reste sur le sur le charbon si
vous le permettre il faut quand même
redonné les ordres de grandeur de cours
on parle en ce moment 87 % des besoins
d'énergie sont satisfaits par les
fossiles 33% pétrole 25% gaz 30% charbon
le reste 10 % de renouvelables y compris
le bio renouvela lui-même ses 4 5%
et puis nucléaire on va pas changer 87%
des énergies comme ça du jour au
lendemain avec des renouvelables si vous
donner un petit exemple une station
service la courbe voir 3500
milliers de mètres cubes par an c'est
l'équivalent de trois terrains de
football de cellules photovoltaïques
donc de salaires de solaire etc
si vous voulez les enjeux sont tels et
puissent intermittent à le soleil faut
autant qu'on sera pas stocker
l'électricité on aura des problèmes
je ne dis pas qu'il faut pas aller vers
les renouvelables il faut absolument le
faire il faut jouer l'efficacité
énergétique c'est-à-dire faut consommer
mois et mieux sur ce qui concerne le
pétrole brut et du pétrole c'est fini
c'est dépassé par contre il ya toute la
problématique de mobilité
et puis à la problématique de génération
électricité vous savez qu'aujourd'hui il
ya 1.5 milliard d'habitants sur cette
planète qui n'a pas accès électricité et
on a dit tout à l'heure qui en a il y en
a deux autres ou deux points ça compte
qu'ils vont arriver le premier besoin de
la planète c'est satisfaire des besoins
en électricité
qu'est ce que vous avez comme solution
nucléaire ça restera fait pour tout ce
qu'on connaît charbon monsieur on a
parlé c'est le plus mauvais c'est le
plus pognon c'est pas la voix
entreprendre la voie la plus réaliste
c'est le gaz
parce que et moi ce que je crois est
tout l agence internationale de
l'énergie et tous les experts vous
disent qu on baissera la consommation de
pétrole mais modestement il faut
absolument collective entre la moyens de
baisser la consommation de charbon mais
la consommation de gaz et l'augmentera
philippe bihouix je vais essayer de
mettre tout le monde d'accord
pascal c'est très enthousiaste
finalement comme c'est déjà en train de
se passer et que deutsche bank est
d'accord on fait juste à attendre
il faut accélérer c'est un accord pour
accélérer le pas ce qu'on va pas assez
bien pourquoi ça marche pas tout à fait
il ya quand même garder jal et les
renouvelables malheureusement c'est pas
toujours très jolie et très vert je veux
dire dans les renouvelables ya aussi le
barrage des trois gorges en chine il ya
un belo horizonte au brésil en face est
du massif hydraulique et puis enfin ça
abîme un peu les forêts tout ça ça fait
des choses aussi donc c'est pas parfait
ensuite l'autre aspect c'est que le
problème c'est que les installations
parle bien de nouvelles installations et
en fait c'est un accompagnement de la
croissance et donc effectivement on est
en train d'installer de plus en plus de
renouvelable mais qui s'ajoute à ce qu
est déjà été installés dans les grandes
années
de l'industrialisation et l'urbanisation
de la chine on va dire la décennie 2000
à 2010 la chine installer une centrale à
charbon par semaine
dakar où est installé le parc
l'équipement du parc nucléaire français
tous les ans d'accord et ses règles
d'amortissement comptable soixante dix
prochaines années et elles sont pas
prévues pour capter du co2 faire je sais
pas quoi danser c'est voilà elles vont
s'étendre à celle là qui a placé les
remplacer avec ce train nous qui
paierons donc il ya deux problèmes qu'on
confond souvent si je peux c'est
remplacer ce qui existe et rajouter des
trucs qui vont bien rajouter des trucs
qui vont bien c'est beaucoup plus facile
que de remplacer ce qui existe philippe
bihouix moi je pense qu'on n'est pas
capable effectivement deux ans il ya
pour moi y'a des écologistes de l'offre
et les écologistes de la demande voilà
on est un peu tous ce soir quelque part
des écologistes de l'offre c'est-à-dire
on dit mais moi je veux effectivement
des choses qui sont décarbonés évident
idéalement pour les plus ultras enfin
dénucléarisé tant qu'à faire donc pas de
carbone pas de nucléaire
mais par contre je veux rien changé à
mon mode de vie à ma mobilité à
l'électricité voilà et donc
malheureusement pour faire ça
c'est ça va être très très compliqué
d'ailleurs je gérais la solution et
surtout si les autres veulent ou surtout
si la zone jalousie ni accéder et que on
va avoir du mal à se passer en donneur
de leçons et d'ailleurs c'est bien tout
le problème des négociations entre les
pays du nord et pays du sud c'est que
tant qu'on n'a pas trouvé un autre
modèle nous pour sortir de l'hyper
mobilité etc
je vois pas pourquoi les indiens dirais
pas moi j'ai envie de faire pareil
également voilà donc après les
écologistes faut faire fort à mon avis
passer assure un autre cap c'est à dire
là le cap de la sobriété seller
l'écologiste de la demande
et justement les corridas devant ils se
demandent pourquoi au même moment où on
fait des grands programmes d'éolien
offshore par exemple en france donc ils
sont subventionnés en même temps on
égrène les rues de panneaux
publicitaires
on laisse tout à lui mais on a des
écrans plats dans les boulangeries voilà
c'est ça cette question là c'est que
dans les deux affaires
j'oppose les deux parce que il faudrait
commencer par essayer de faire la
sobriété débrancher les choses et où il
faire les deux mais malheureusement on
n'en fait qu'un des deux suspects ayant
vous vous dites qu'il faut
impérativement réduire notre
consommation d'énergie quoi qu'il arrive
on aura là on doit la réduire mais ça
arrive à 7 en place à l'information
changent mais j'aime bien le faire si je
peux me permettre au nez comme dans un
système économique extrêmement paresseux
dire paresseux au sens où mon bien soyez
beaucoup progrès et beaucoup de
technologies qui sont embarqués dans
notre modèle mais mais si je reviens par
exemple le pétrole le pétrole est un âge
d'or où il suffisait de creuser la terre
ils jaillissent et il n'y avait pas de
technologie embarquée pour faire jaillir
du pétrole donc ce modèle là il n'est
pas resté au sens où je prélève je
transforme je jette et puis maintenant
on se dit que ça a des conséquences
aussi bien en amont et en aval de la
chaîne de valeur mais une chose qui est
sûre c'est que là dans la transition
écologique énergétique est devant nous
il va falloir aussi investir massivement
parce qu'on a des verrous technologiques
à faire sauter pour que ça aille plus
vite
ces verrous technologiques par exemple
je pense non la pile à combustible
hydrogène à 98 % du parc automobile qui
est complètement pour l'instant avec le
bon vieux moteur thermique avec un
rendement qui est pas extraordinaire
donc on a des verrous sur le stockage de
l'électricité savoir stocker
l'électricité
moi je parle même pas de le la de la
fusion nucléaire parce que ça nous
renvoie à quelque chose qui est de
l'ordre de la guerre des étoiles
mais c'est pour dire qu'il faut
maintenant impérativement faire
transiter un financement qui a été
largement sur les énergies fossiles qui
en ont bien profité
vers des énergies des fossilisé le seul
souci c'est que et pascal a mentionné on
a encore un petit problème de réglage
dans les investissements et ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est les énergies
renouvelables aujourd'hui sans
subvention arrive à être plus
compétitives que les énergies fossiles
et l'énergie nucléaire c'est ce que
m'ont l'air de dire à 100 je vous
propose de regarder juste et vous
interviendrez ce qu'on dit alors
effectivement il est énergies fossiles
remplacer ou pas par les énergies
renouvelables vu à la télévision regarde
10 éoliennes
de plus en plus nombreuses des
kilomètres carrés de nouveaux panneaux
solaires aujourd'hui les énergies
renouvelables d'école les
investissements mondiaux dans les
énergies renouvelables et les
technologies vertes continuent
d'augmenter + 16 % en 2014 soit 300
milliards d'euros ce chiffre devrait
doubler d'ici 2020 mais il est encore
insignifiant comparé aux 4 1700
milliards d'euros dépensés chaque année
par les états pour continuer de soutenir
les énergies fossiles les énergies
fossiles
nous les utilisons pour faire rouler nos
voitures chauffer ou éclairer nos
maisons ces dérivés vous servent à
fabriquer le plastique de nos brosses à
dents et les coques de nos téléphones
elles fournissent plus de 80% de
l'énergie que nous consommons grâce au
pétrole 31% au charbon 29 au gaz naturel
21 le renoncement aux énergies fossiles
priverez les compagnies pétrolières de
leur principale source de revenus alors
que les réserves ne se tarisse pas au
contraire entre 2002 et 2012
les réserves de gaz ont même augmenté de
21% en fait les nouvelles techniques de
forage permettent aujourd'hui
d'exploiter les hydrocarbures à grande
profondeur au large du brésil par
exemple ou dans les schistes du sous sol
américain leur exploitation sera plus
coûteuse dans le même temps l'éolien et
le solaire deviendront plus rentable
alors ces énergies renouvelables
deviendront elles aussi compétitif que
le nucléaire qui représente les trois
quarts de l'électricité produite en
france
l'idée fait désormais l'objet d'un
rapport de l' agence de l'énergie et ses
conclusions sont surprenantes en 2050
produire de l'énergie 100% renouvelable
ne coûterait que 50,4 milliards d'euros
par an à peine plus cher que le
nucléaire énergie renouvelable au
nucléaire
la question relève surtout d'un choix
politique qui pour l'heure est loin
d'être tranché c'est juste un choix
politique que je faisais entre les
énergies renouvelables les énergies
nucléaires si c'était le cas alors
d'abord je rappelle que le nucléaire
fait pas de co2 donc choisir entre les
renouvelables et le nucléaire c'est un
débat de deuxième rang si on s'occupe du
seuil du changement climatique si on
s'occupe du changement climatique
on choisit entre fossiles n'est pas
possible c'est ça le débat de premier
rang la france a du reste une
sensibilité particulière sur le
nucléaire qu'on ne retrouve pas
nécessairement dans tous les autres pays
du monde la possibilité de particulière
c'est que on en a beaucoup et qu'en même
temps on n'aime pas ça oui on en a un
peu le nucléaire honteux on en fait mais
enfin si ça pouvait pas trop savoir le
sur la question arts le rapport ademe
par des mois je veux dire sénat du grand
n'importe quoi
ils ont utilisé une méthode qui n'était
pas valide pour un résultat à mon avis
écrits d' avance mais bon comme le
journaliste n'a pas les moyens d'aller
regarder dans le détail ce qu'ils ont
fait il prend la conclusion en disant
bon c'est l'état qui me raconte ça doit
être vrai malheureusement la réalité est
plus complexe que ça quand on quand on
regarde la question pour laquelle c'est
difficile
vous allez comprendre tout de suite
quand on regarde l'histoire ce qui s'est
passé dans l'histoire c'est que
historiquement on a démarré la
civilisation humaine avec des énergies
renouvelables nos ancêtres utilisaient
du bois parfaitement renouvelables ont
fait avancer les premiers bateaux avec
du vent parfaitement renouvelables ont
fait tourner les premiers moulins avec
de l'eau et du vent parfaitement
renouvelables exercé chez les aliments
au soleil parfaitement renouvelables
pourquoi est-ce qu'on est passé aux
énergies fossiles si les roadmaps et
mieux aucune raison de le faire
en fait on y est passé et penser la
gibecière bientôt non non non non parce
que la physique et que dire les
questions non non c'est pas une
caricature c'est ce qui s'est passé
historiquement et la physique nous dit
que tant qu'on a plein de problèmes ni
d'exutoire c'est à dire le changement
climatique ni d'accès aux stocks
c'est à dire de pics de production parce
qu'on est déjà en train de sentir en
europe et bien les énergies fossiles
sont imbattables en termes de qualités
physiques parce qu'elles sont très
concentré très facile à utiliser
donc du coup pour ces raisons là elles
demandent moins de travail pour aller
chercher l'énergie l'environnement et
donc elles sont moins chères les cas
particuliers dans lesquelles les
renouvelables arrive à être moins cher
que le fossile sont des cas dans
lesquels on ne paye pas tous les coûts
et en particulier l'électricité qu'on
appelle non pilotable donc le vent ou le
soleil
il faut lui adjoindre qu'on appelle du
service système pour que le rer puissent
quand même avancé quand vous avez besoin
d'aller au boulot ou que le
réfrigérateur tourner quand même quand
vous alors pouvait décaler un peu
enfin s'il n'y a pas de vent pendant une
semaine votre pile de linge sale elle va
commencer à sentir france
vous pouvez et la télé étant unis n'est
plus en noir et blanc et et ben non
c'est ce que celle ci avec et eurent
aussi regarder l'avenir et pas le passé
alors j'ai pas interrompu donc le nom je
suis je suis juste en train de dire que
la raison pour laquelle historiquement
ça s'est passé comme ça et ça s'est
passé comme ça dans tous les pays du
monde ça s'est pas passé comme ça juste
en france parce qu'on est des affreux
jojo et qu'on aime bien le fossile et
notre voiture
c'est pour des raisons physiques il ya
vraiment des déterminants physique à ça
donc j'ai dis pas qu'il faut pas faire
le chemin inverse
je dis que de croire que l'on va faire
le chemin inverse avec les gens qui vont
continuer à augmenter leur pouvoir
d'achat à leur consommation etc
malheureusement c'est se bercer
d'illusions donc aujourd'hui faut
choisir son confort à court terme encore
une minute monsieur le bourreau après on
s'en fout ou bien on commence à faire
des efforts collectifs l'on peut les
faire plus malins ou moins malins mais
on n'est malheureusement plus dans une
équation où on peut avoir fromage et
dessert voilà c'est pas nécessairement
très grave mais c'est mieux de savoir
qu'on est dans ce cas là avec soi zone
et je pense qu'on peut avoir le fromage
et le dessert c'était juste pas le même
fromage est pas le même dessert mais je
pense qu'on en revient à l'idée de la
sobriété énergétique et pas forcément un
concept un fardeau pour l'avenir au
contraire s'appelle konami qu'un c'est
très intéressant la manière dont la
société civile de crise en plus
s'élargit écrit un mouvement autour du
climat parce que quand on regarde sur
les territoires ce qui se passait
énormément de l'alternative du temps
c'est le livre c'est votre livre sur
l'idée qu' effectivement que les gens
qui sont des solutions de demain qui
vont créer des emplois qui vont faire
vivre l'économie autrement et pas
forcément dans l'augmentation permanente
je ne sais quoi d'ailleurs ce que je
pense qu'on a assez de portables comme
ça c'était les visions et assez d'écran
c'est justement des acteurs qui sont les
locaux qui ont déjà des recycleries des
ressourceries qui font une économie
autrement et qui est tout aussi agréable
et surtout qui crée du lien social qui
créent des emplois
donc c'est pas enfin je pense pas qu'il
faille mettre en d'abord l'impression
que ce qui vient après va être pire au
contraire je pense que c'est le fameux
changement de civilisation dont on parle
et c'est vrai que dans la négociation le
problème c'est qu'elle l'attend quand on
parle de transition énergétique souvent
la région effectivement trop à énergies
renouvelables ou encore autre chose mais
en tout cas c'est pas que les énergies
renouvelables c'est effectivement aussi
la réduction de la consommation
d'énergie notamment dans nos pays parce
que clairement je crois qu'il ya un
rapport d'oxfam qui est sorti cette
semaine
10% des personnes les plus riches dans
le monde consomment et émettre 50 % des
gaz à effet de serre donc on peut aussi
facilement
agir sur notre consommation à nous et
permettre à d'autres effectivement qui
vont pas l'afrique va pas s'arrêter
d'émettre des gaz à effet de serre ils
vont forcément augmenter un petit peu
l'enjeu c'est juste qu'ils augmentent
pas exponentiellement avec qu'ils
augmentent comme ça et donc de leur
laisser cette place cet espace carbone
comme on dit et nous en échange en
progrès on progresse à la bourse de hong
hong et en consomme de toute façon tant
très très peu après un scénario d'evan
mosher 15,2 milliards en 2005 croisement
et c'est là où justement on va bien la
question des financements ou est ce
qu'on va mettre nos travaux alors pascal
canfin que oui je voulais dire que deux
choses d'abord si la chine on n'a pas eu
de la chine et du charbon
si la chine est en train progressivement
de diminuer ses émissions de co2 liées
au charbon
ça a commencé l'année dernière encore
une fois tout ça est nouveau on ne va
pas assez vite c'est pour ça qu'on est
en train de perdre la course de vitesse
contre le climat c'est pour ça qu'il
faut un accord pour ça qu'il faut
accélérer je dis pas que tout va bien
tout est réglé évidemment non mais faut
quand même donner des signaux d'espoir
esperce c'est de percevoir ce qui est en
train de changer et qui est en train de
dessiner l'avenir
la chine a fait pour la première fois ce
qu'on appelle le pit charbon la dernière
c'est à dire que ces émissions baisse
due au charbon pourquoi parce que les la
pollution de l'air dans les villes
chinoises est absolument dramatique
vous savez que respirer une journée à
pékin ces fumées 40 cigarettes ont même
d'avoir commencé à fumer pour ce qui fut
bon donc la première cause de
mécontentement des classes moyennes
chinoises en ville ces sont les
questions environnementales
donc les chinois sont en train de durcir
les règles sur le charbon
du coup le charbon est plus cher et du
coup ça ça accélère puisque le charbon
et en plus cher les renouvelables qui
sont déjà presque compétitive passe en
dessous et ça s'accélère et deuxièmement
les messages que je veux dire c'est
quand même ce qu'on est en train de voir
et notamment en californie
c'est que on est en train de faire la
jonction entre la révolution numérique
de l'internet et la révolution
l'économie verte et quand on fait les
deux eh bien on a cependant un
changement profond de modèle et quand
j'écoute que ce soit jean marc jancovici
ou quand je sois le représentant du
lobby pétrolier j'ai l'impression que
ont par exemple c'était inimaginable si
je vous avais posé la question il ya 30
ans est ce qu'un jour vous vous
arriveriez a envoyé un courrier en une
nanoseconde à l'autre bout de la terre
vous m'auriez dit mais jamais de la vie
vous rêvez vous êtes un utopiste assez
bien les écolos ça non on maintenant on
le fait trente ans plus tard c'est une
évidence et un dernier exemple pour
compris
conscience qu'en quinze vingt ans on
peut radicalement changer en 1900 tous
les prévisionnistes qui regardaient la
ville de paris lise est la plus grande
menace sur la ville de paris c'est quoi
c'est le crottin de cheval
parce qu'avec 80 mille chevaux à paris
et puis quand on faisait quand vous la
courbe alors on prolonge on prolonge on
prolonge jamais on pourra se passer de
crottin de cheval
évidemment paris croule sous le prochain
le cheval ça ne s'est pas produit en
quinze ans il n'y avait plus une
diligence plus un cheval dans paris
parce qu'on a inventé la voiture est
donc aujourd'hui on est face à la même
logique est de dire on fait cette
révolution industrielle et tous ceux qui
ont fait les énergies du 20e siècle
bravo à vous mais c'est le passé
j'allais dire non mais je crois qu'il
serait quand même malhonnête de ne pas
reconnaître les bienfaits de apporter la
civilisation par le charme ont d'abord
toute la civilisation industrielle
climat tant par le pétrole vient de
signer l'ouverture du monde
alors maintenant il faut changer mais
ceci dit je crois qu'on oublie les
réalités je vais encore donner deux
trois chiffres
la consommation en énergie elle va pas
rester figé autres maintenant et 2030
ses 15 ans pas beaucoup vous savez de
combien elle va augmenter la
consommation d'énergie planète + 25 %
je passe à 2050 combien + 37 % donc les
besoins énergétiques sont énormes on va
pas résoudre ça a pour l'instant parce
que la technologie moi je suis d'accord
avec monsieur ça va évoluer il faut
avoir confiance ou faire confiance mais
faut surtout pas opposer les énergies
entre elles
c'est une mauvaise bagarre deuxièmement
il faut pas faire peur aux gens
on bâtit pas une civilisation sur la
peur donc il faut qu'on travaille
ensemble on voit les meilleures
solutions
mais madame parlait de réduction de
consommation
mais bien sûr que ça arrive vous
rappelez tous des voitures il ya encore
dix ans qui consommait de 12 litres aux
cent c'est quoi aujourd'hui les nouveaux
les nouveaux véhicules qui sortent et
véhicules neufs
ces quatre voire 3 litres au cent
l'objectif est bon c'est tous les ans et
ses deux oubliés volkswagen qui un
mauvais débat je reconnais mais ces
salles efficace énergétique dans les
usines
on a réduit considérablement moins 30%
donc on travaille touche et d'ailleurs
ce qui se passe dans les pays développés
de l' ocde la consommation d'énergie va
pas augmenter
ceci dit en europe chez désolé monsieur
elle va rester constante contre
maintenant à 2050
mais là où elle va augmenter beaucoup
c'est dans les pays émergents dans les
pays en développement
on leur dit à ces gens là ne consommait
plus non qu'est ce qu'ils veulent ils
veulent des réfrigérateurs
ils veulent des voitures ils veulent de
l'électricité comment produit
électricité derniers chiffres vous savez
si on remplaçait ses 50 millions de
tonnes de carburants consommés en france
par an vous savez combien de centrales p
r tito père il faudrait pour remplacer
sa part électricité 18 centrales le père
en plus de ce qu'on a je parle même pas
de les réduire
18 ans plus si vous remplacez ça on ne
peut pas de nucléaire on veut des
centrales photovoltaïques
il faut deux fois la surface du
luxembourg vous pensez que c'est
réaliste mais non moi je crois pas du
tout à fait libre de 8
qu'est ce que ces vraies questions sont
posées
c'est à dire que qu'est ce qu'on fait
pour qu'est ce qu'on met à la place
d'abord et comment on oblige les gens à
ne plus consommer d'énergies fossiles
je pense qu'on peut pas on peut pas
fonder une civilisation sur le mensonge
on peut pas non plus fourni une
civilisation sur le mythe a rien comme
une énorme différence entre le crottin
de cheval parisien de la fin du xixème
siècle et les connu look l'économie
verte numérique californienne c'est que
le crottin de cheval c'est biodégradable
or les 42 millions de blogs les 42
millions de tonnes de déchets
électroniques qu'on a produit lui ment
l'année dernière et qui finissent au
ghana accueil ou en chine en inde et
c'est cela qui polluent les nappes
phréatiques et c'est l'économie
numérique donc dire que l'économie
numérique s'est complètement vert mais
en plus un moment où on est en train de
développer tous les centres de données
consomment déjà 10 % 10 % de
l'électricité mondiale et la croissance
est hallucinante et ses déficits et pour
la plupart au charbon à part un ou deux
trucs peut-être de google en finlande
bon voilà donc on a quand même on a
quand même un problème moi je suis
étonné qu'on se dise aujourd'hui on voit
bien qu'on va dans un mur on voit bien
qu'on est dans un mur en soi parce que
on y va
on n'arrivera pas changer les choses
assez vite soit parce qu'on n'est pas la
bonne échelle vaut le city effectivement
tout à l'heure avec l'épreuve de surface
on earth la matérialité du monde et de
et de sa finitude
donc moi je suis étonné que on en soit
encore là et que la sobriété face si
peur parce que on en a tellement sous le
pied le gâchis est tellement énorme
juste quelques exemples on jette en
europe 25 à 30 % de la nourriture à la
poubelle 25 à 30%
mais les émeutes de la pierre de ce qui
est produit un tiers de ce qui est
produit
on reçoit chacun enfin pas chacun mais
l'ensemble des français reçoivent un
million de tonnes de prospectus
publicitaires non désirées dans leur
boîte aux lettres chaque année à quoi ça
sert d'imprimer d'utiliser des
ressources des mois chacun on reçoit un
minimum
l'ensemble me suis repris rendez-vous
peut-être mais c'est possible
et voilà c'est vous que les renvoyer
après j'en sais rien on préfère on
préfère acheter des des pneus low cost
en asie du sud est
alors qu'on pourrait rechapés les pneus
vous savez de changer la bande de
roulement seulement c'est fait pour les
camions c'est fait pour les avions n'y a
pas de preuves de sécurité on ne
réchappe eu les pneus aujourd'hui les
voitures particulières en europe pour en
france on pourrait diviser par 3 d'un
claquement de doigts sans aucun problème
sécuritaire le truc ce que vous disiez
parce que je citais de votre livre il
faudrait réparer l'électroménager
réparer la formation et et et les
chiffonniers les cordonniers deviendront
nos héros absolu c'est ce que vous nous
proposez pour qu'on soit cohérent alors
mais en attendant parce que pour faire
ça il faut faire pas mal d'évolutions
réglementaires administratives fiscales
juridiques culte d'amon il ya un peu
tout ça en attendant il ya plein de
choses à faire sur la voiture par
exemple on est en train d'y on n'a pas
le choix on n'a pas le choix on est en
train d'essayer de se battre pour aller
vers la voiture à 2 litres aux cent mais
moi je fais demain matin la voiture à 1
litres aux cent j'ai pas besoin de tous
les grands programmes d'ingénieurs
simplement elle fait moins de 500 kg
elle dépasse pas 70 km heure alors c'est
vrai que ça met un peu en cause le
modèle de la berline allemande de
fonction bon c'est ce que vous appelez
les basses technologies elle aurait
effectivement la basse et je sais qu'en
plus c'est les voitures se sont enrichis
en équipement parce qu'on supporte plus
de boucher les rétroviseurs
il faut des petits moteurs il faut
plaindre qu'elle est c'est tout ça ça
valait dans la grande bretagne heuzé
dans le four électrique à la fin donc ça
va gâcher des ressources évidemment et
donc on pourrait effectivement un peu d
équipes est d équiper une partie de nos
équipements alors je commencerai pas par
ça mais pour vous citer par exemple ce
qu'il ya dans un smartphone vous savez
qu'il ya une station météorologique
complet
hygromètre remettre thermomètre on a un
gyroscope à 3 axes en ex
d'accéléromètres ça c'est pour jouer à
flight simulator
mais dans le temps et dans les
transports en commun idéalement parce
que faut pas faire ça au volant on le
fera bientôt avec la voiture tonneau
voilà donc si on si on laisse tout ça
dans nos smartphone on aura beau essayer
de les échos concevoir en aura beau
essayer de les réparer faire durer c'est
un gâchis phénoménal de ressources et
d'énergie mal donc il faut qu'on se
calme d'une manière ou d'une autre on
peut commencer par les gros trucs sans
doute la voiture
le poids de la voiture la vitesse de la
voiture qu'est ce qui nous empêche alors
c'est liberticide évidemment vous savez
que j'ai pas le droit de circuler sur
l'autoroute avec un char d'assaut
c'est interdit en france l'état est
liberticide 1 parce qu'évidemment la
liberté des uns commence la cour
pourquoi est ce que demain matin a pas
de voir la dame au 1er janvier 2018 je
dis pas la voiture immatriculée blanc
france en europe ce sera une tonne pas
une de plus et puis l'année d'après ce
sera à 980 kg et un après 970 au
parlement validant sa lame occasion vous
pouvez aussi limiter le nombre de
billets d'avion que chacun a le droit de
prendre
voilà alors fois attaqué par les bons
combats la voiture est cohérent c'est
assez cohérent ou d'avoir effectivement
une logique de rationnement geneviève
féraud rien pour revenir vers vous une
seconde quand je disais qu'on est dans
une économie paresseuse en effectivement
dans ce modèle par sd à dire aux sources
infinies je transforme production de
déchets infini ce qu'on appelle le
système linéaire on le connaît pas ça
une économie circulaire est ce que vous
vous rendez compte de la révolution que
ça représente de passer l'économie
circulaire il faut rappeler juste les
d'économiser reconnu le circulaire c'est
tout simplement cette logique qui est je
produis avec des ressources limitées éco
conçus et si possible renouvelables dans
tout le site de fabrication que joe
petit mise jeu mutualisent j'économise
de la ressource et puis je produis
idéalement zéro déchet ou les déchets
que je vais produire ce gp seront
recyclables mais là on est dans un rêve
d'alchimiste en aidant et je parle même
pas des énergies fossiles
parce que si on fait tout ça avec des
matériaux biosourcés éco-conception et
il faut juste comprendre que le modèle
économique de l'intégralité des
entreprises aujourd'hui qui propose des
services et des biens à 7 milliards de
personnes qui d'ailleurs n'en demande
pas autant ça c'est vrai donc on a
aujourd'hui 7 milliards de personnes qui
se lèvent le matin pour aller produire
fabriquer des biens pour les autres
autres milliards de l'humanité qui n'ont
pas toujours besoin sur un modèle
d'économie linéaire essayé à les voir
n'importe quelle entreprise je vous mets
au défi de dire comment votre système de
production linéaire comment je peux le
rendre circulaire alors on n'est plus du
tout dans le même modèle économique
on n'est plus dans une logique de volume
on est dans une logique d'économie de la
ressource et là on réalise plus du tout
les mêmes chiffres d'affaires les mêmes
marges c'est pas lui même métier les
chaînes de valeur se modifie et je peux
vous dire que c'est quelque chose qui
trotte dans la tête de tout le monde
mais le mettre en oeuvre de façon
opérationnelle est embarqué
l'intégralité de la population vers ce
modèle là qui est effectivement la seule
pour moi la seule issue parce que sinon
si on reste dans ce modèle paraît ce qui
génère des inégalités et des déchets on
va dans le mur
mais cette idée est de faire mieux avec
moins
et bien que je considère moi comme une
formidable frontières pour moi c'est la
nouvelle frontière du progrès et donc je
ne dis pas qu'il ya plus de progrès au
contraire je dis mais attendez que tous
les ingénieurs de la terre que tous les
scientifiques de la terre se retrousse
les manches on n'a pas dire qu'il
fallait remonter sur les arbres manger
des feuilles ont dit que on a un nouveau
mythe prométhéen devant nous qui est de
faire mieux avec moins
c'est une formidable histoire ça
s'appelle ça s'appelle de dettes la
tempérance par rapport à libris
mais ça ça n'intéresse pas grand monde
parce que il n'ya pas je sais pas il n'y
a pas quelque chose qui embarque avec
des machines folles avec une sorte de
deux des mesures non non non seulement
il va falloir faire mieux avec moins
mais en plus il va falloir payer pour
les autres d'après ce que nous vous nous
avez dit puisqu'il ya effectivement les
pays émergents et les pays en voie de
développement qui est a priori ont
beaucoup moins polluer l'atmosphère que
nous et qui nous disent évidemment que
ce serait bien enfin je crois que
françois lenglet dit lui même on a une
dette écologique envers eux notamment
envers les africains regardent et les
dirigeants du g8 achever leur sommet à
l'aquila en italie il a beaucoup été
question des changements climatiques
aujourd'hui plusieurs dirigeants de pays
émergents comme la chine l'inde ou le
brésil étaient également invités ils ont
redit leur difficulté à concilier
développement économique et préservation
de l'environnement
je dois dire que je ne crois pas qu'il
soit vraiment utile de discuter
davantage sur les financements puisque
les anciennes promesses sont restées
sans lendemain
si je comptabilise les sommes qui ont
été promises
c'est au moins 2,5 milliards de dollars
où ils sont
ce qui est difficile c'est parce que les
grands pour lui et ne veulent pas mettre
la main à la poche pour aider les pays
comme et lumière à s'engager dans ce
processus de réduction
la solidarité avec les pays en
développement qui subissent des pertes
matérielles et humaines doit absolument
apparaître dans cet accord la tête
m cet homme monsieur maudit le premier
ministre indien l'a dit en substance si
les 100 milliards par an ne sont pas
réunies pour être versé aux pays les
plus pauvres pour faire la transition
énergétique
ils ne voteront pas l'accord les pays
développés doivent se montrer à la
hauteur de leurs engagements en
mobilisant 100 milliards de dollars par
an jusqu'en 2020 après 2020 il faut que
cet appui financier augmente une coque
21 marqué ce matin par un sommet
réunissant le prévenant au lynx et une
douzaine de chefs d'état africains
il y a une dette écologique que le monde
et en particulier le monde développé
doit régler à l'égard du continent
africain et le chef de l'état a annoncé
tout à l'heure que la france allait
consacrer une 2 milliards d'euros au
développement des énergies renouvelables
en afrique et ce d'ici 2012 alors est-ce
qu'il va falloir payer pour pour tous
les pays qui ne sont pas développées
aussi vite que nous enfin mettons-nous
une seconde une seconde à la place d'un
jeune sénégalais qui vit à dakar qui
voit la mer monte moi j étais quand
j'étais au gouvernement dans la baie de
dakar vous avez l'océan qui monte et les
villages qui sont mangés par la montée
de l'océan et il dit là c'était le stade
de foot
là c'était l'école là c'était ma maison
il n'y a plus rien qu'est ce qu'il vient
ce jeune sénégalais d'abord il va
ailleurs au sénégal puis peut-être
ailleurs en afrique puis peut-être à la
fin il meurt au fond de la méditerranée
est donc l'enjeu énergétique
l'enjeu climatique c'est d'abord un
enjeu de civilisation il faut jamais
perdre de vue c'est pas que des calculs
macroéconomique et des courbes de
rentabilité etc
c'est un enjeu de civilisation et donc
d'apporter l'énergie transformer cette
pauvreté extrême dans quelque chose qui
soit vivable c'est un enjeu de
civilisation millions en 2050 2
milliards dont 1 milliard de moi mais la
question est donc voilà on peut pas dire
on va pas payer
et puis en même temps on va les laisser
là et jamais viendront chez nous ou
jamais évidemment évidemment ils
viendront ils auront raison parce qu à
leur place je ferais exactement la même
chose exactement la même chose et donc
soit on est à la hauteur de ce défi soit
on ferme les yeux et à la fin on sait
que c'est c'est vraiment pas un avenir
qu'on a envie de vivre
donc oui il va falloir payer un peu
pourquoi un peu parce qu'en font ça
coûte très peu cher on parle des 100
milliards dans le reportage manière tout
à fait justifié ce que vous connaissez
ce chiffre la totalité des
investissements annuels dans les
infrastructures dans le monde
ces cinq mille milliards de dollars donc
ça veut dire que en fait on parle d'une
petite petit bout d'argent deuxièmement
aujourd'hui quand on regarde les
subventions donc notre argent l'argent
public l'argent des impôts l'argent du
contribuable qui va vers les énergies
fossiles est beaucoup plus élevé c'est
le fmi qui le dit beaucoup plus élevé
que l'énergie les mêmes subventions qui
vont vers les énergies renouvelables
et donc on prendrait un peu de cet
argent qui va subventionner les énergies
fossiles qui sont à l'origine du
problème pour les travailleuses du verre
la transition énergétique au sud
ça veut pas dire dépenser plus ça veut
dire dépenser mieux de la même manière
que l'idée c'est de réinventer nos
modèles économiques pas pour produire
moins et que ça mais pour produire mieux
c'est une révolution de l'intelligence
on est plus concave ans non on est
beaucoup plus intelligent pourquoi on
n'y arriverait pas française du son nom
j'adhère complètement je crois qu'on a
un ça va
ceci dit la vraie question c'est ce
qu'il faut dépenser tout cet argent du
renouvela parce que monsieur dit que
c'est moins en moins cher je reconnais
sur le solaire peut-être par contre les
éoliennes offshore je crois pas du tout
d'abord c'est très cher en
investissement
ce sera très cher en maintenance est-ce
qu'il faut pas mettre tout cet argent
dans la recherche
moi j'ai lu monsieur tyrol prix nobel
d'économie c'est sa proposition en
disant je suis pas sûr du résultat
mettons beaucoup plus le paquet dans la
recherche pour changer les processus
pour améliorer l'efficacité pour faire
ces choses là c'est parce qu'on fait en
france
je me permet quand même de dire que les
énergies renouvelables sont sont
subventionnés en france cette année 6
milliards pour deux ans huit dans trois
ans après ce sera 15
il faut le financer peut-être à un choix
de société c'est un choix politique mais
le problème le ce a renchéri le coût de
l'énergie en france jeu sera à peu près
pareil en europe
est ce qu'on peut se le permettre est ce
qu'on veut faire ça quand moi je suis
frappé par un sondage quand on demande
aux français ce que vous êtes prêts à
payer pour qu'on ait plus de
renouvelable pour protéger le climat
j'ai lu un sondage qui disaient oui 50
euros pas plus
et qu'est ce qu'on est en train de faire
là la décision des politiques ça a été
de dire cette taxe sur l'électricité
elle va passer comme une taxe sur les
carburants et fioul domestique
ça va pénaliser le pouvoir d'achat des
gens et surtout plus grave à mon avis ça
va rendre nos entreprises moins
compétitives et vous savez tout ce qu'on
a perdu 10 points dont le pib de
l'industrie est ce que c'est vraiment ça
qu'on veut faire le problème principal
je crois c'est que on ne peut pas
dissocier compétitivité des entreprises
et coûts de l'énergie
donc je suis désolé c'est vrai que cdc
des courses et des extrapolations c'est
des calculs la mzl pas d'accord
bassement matérielles mais on est obligé
de se poser cette question est ce qu'on
veut pénaliser le pouvoir d'achat des
français qui ont besoin de leur bagnole
diesel pour aller pour aller bosser tous
les jours en zone rurale je sais pas
évident la réponse
alors justement votre avis jean marc
jancovici c'est compliqué d'avoir un
avis parce que parce que ça fasse non ça
renvoie un renvoi au thème de mon livre
c'est que dans tout ce que j'entends
depuis
trois quarts d'heure il ya une assertion
de départ pour raisonner que ce soit
dans les sujets que vous avez montré ou
etc ou dans les choses qui ont pu être
dit ici - mais qui ne correspond pas à
la réalité ou qui correspond à une
manière de voir la réalité qui est un
peu spécieuse donc à partir de là c'est
un peu compliqué d'avoir un avis je suis
parfaitement d'accord avec ce qu'a dit
philippe bihouix les arbres montent pas
jusqu'au ciel et sur une planète finie
malheureusement la croissance
perpétuelle ça n'existe pas même la
consommation perpétuellement constante
de quelque chose ça n'existe pas donc à
un moment il va falloir gérer la
sobriété et il vaut mieux la dezir est
plutôt que la subir
je suis une espèce très bizarre ou nerfs
beaucoup de gens je suis un décroissante
east pro nucléaire voilà j'en fais
partie cros et je dis pas la
décroissance il la faut parce qu'elle
est désirable jeudi on va la voir de
toute façon on l'a déjà en ce moment en
europe et si la consommation d'énergie
baisse en europe en ce moment c'est pas
parce qu'on l'a géré c'est parce qu'on
est en train de subir et c'est ça qui
est en train de mettre des gens au
chômage donc les tous les gens ils ont
deux souhaits et c'est très légitime
ils veulent un environnement sain mais
ça ça arrive en deuxième ils veulent
boulot alors parce que nous là on est en
train de réfléchir entre csp + qui
sommes bien payés mais enfin ce n'est
pas le cas de tous les gens qui sont en
train de nous regarder
il se trouve que le boulot il arrive
parce que quelque part quelqu'un de
l'argent pour payer les gens et cet
argent le système économique qu'on a
bâti depuis deux siècles est ainsi fait
fi comme ça que il est issu non pas du
travail des gens mais du travail les
machines et plus les machines
travaillent et transforme de choses
chères un philippe bihouix et plus on a
l'argent c'est comme ça que ça marche
donc si on veut avoir moins de choses de
trucs des machins et de bidules parce
que c'est ça l'horizon vers lequel il
faut se diriger et je suis d'accord
aussi avec ce qu'a dit geneviève c'est
un formidable défi
du reste les français devraient jeter
dessus au lieu d'être
eh bien la contrepartie économique
inexorable je dis bien inexorable c'est
que ça s'apparente à une forme de
récession structurelles bien ça
s'appelait rend donc une augmentation du
chômage dont c'est non pas du tout eu
tellement ça s'apparente ça s'apparente
à une diminution des revenus réels des
gens c'est à dire qu'avec une heure de
travail vous pourrez vous payer de moins
en moins de frigo de voitures de chevy
ce n'est pas nécessairement un drame
c'est pas ça je leur dis bien payé et on
à la sécurité de l'emploi tous autour de
ce plateau je le redis c'est pas la
préoccupation enfin tout le monde n'a
pas cette chance et je le redis aussi
gérer une société dans laquelle les
revenus diminuent
au lieu d'augmenter c'est un exercice
inédit dans l'histoire humaine ou en
tout cas dans les deux derniers siècles
on sait pas faire ça ça fait huit
générations ont fait l'un vers ce qu'on
n'a pas les réflexes
on n'a pas les outils on n'a pas les
habitudes on n'a pas le schéma mental on
n'a rien de tout ça donc c'est très
désorientant comment on va faire il vaut
mieux faire la danse de la pluie dans
espérant que la croissance va revenir
voilà qui l'a fait cet exercice et
sarkozy avant lui ça marche très bien
donc il vaudrait mieux s'attaquer à ce
que va vraiment être l'avenir du monde
mais ça demande d'avoir un débat un peu
pragmatique - papa idéologique et sa
demande encore une fois de ne pas nier
une réalité économique qui est que si
vous avez moins de trucs et de machins
la contrepartie des trucs et des machins
elle baissera économiquement la réaction
rapide et willeman sur la victoire
effectivement la croissance et l'emploi
la croissance et l'emploi c'est ce qu'on
nous aimait scène en permanence donc
effectivement déjà un peu dire que la
croissance reviendra pas dans les bonnes
au pays je pense que d'ailleurs pas pour
rien que les entreprises vont les
chercher
on cherchait cette croissance dans les
pays émergents ça c'est pas une surprise
même si on fait semblant de pas encore
se le dire et donc alors d'ailleurs elle
ne reverra pas mais c'est pas
souhaitable c'est parce que tu as
puisqu'on ne s'est pas décorée les la
consommation d'énergie et l'émission de
gaz à effet de serre etc
on sait faire sans les économistes
appellent un découplage relatif mais on
sait pas faire un découplage absolue ça
monte comme ça et puis la pollution s'il
ya de la croissance économique qui a
augmenté au cas où la comptable assure
d'énergie donc bien améliorer
l'efficacité mais on n'arrivera pas à
décroître
la gazelle avaient fait d'accord alors
du coup qu'est-ce qu'on fait la
croissance va parvenir à une façon c'est
revenez ce n'est pas souhaitable
alors on reste avec effectivement 5
millions de personnes qui travaillent
pas ou qu'on passait travail qui sont en
temps partiel subi
ou est ce qu'on essaie d'inventer un
autre système industriel commercial
fiscal etc
qu'ils soient alors pour pas se fâcher
on va dire post croissance pour pas
faire trop peur au sens de plein emploi
ou de pleine activité
de mon point de vue c'est parfaitement
atteignable je prends juste un exemple
l'agriculture la folie l'agriculture on
a fait les usines un cochon d'un côté en
bretagne et on nous explique tout le
temps de jeu banjo mais deutsche bank
doit nous expliquer que c'est il faut
les faire plus gros parce que sinon il
faut mettre toujours plus de cochons et
de vaches et non ça marche pas et
l'autre côté la beauce un truc de
délirant il faut revenir de la
polyculture la polyculture élevé plus
petite exploitation plus intensive en
main d'oeuvre et on peut créer un
million d'emplois dans l'agriculture il
faudrait d'ailleurs ici regardez en
afrique il faut absolument il a commencé
pour celle du marché ou si on regarde ya
encore 3 millions d'agriculteurs en
italie par exemple un peu on peut faire
est pas pour rien qu à pas mal de
produits bio qui arrivent d'italie par
exemple c'est bon on peut le faire
simplement à ce moment là on a un
problème c'est que on ne sait pas vendre
notre poulet fermier localement qui a
été sympa et tour contre le poulet
trempé dans le club brésilien
on sait pas faire ça et donc c'est le
problème effectivement soin de la
mondialisation et fait le premier qui
bouge on pourrait faire une transition
on pourrait on a un tous les moyens on
peut d mécanisée des choses au lieu
d'avoir remplacé le personnel à la poste
par des machines et des écrans on a
l'impression de plus faire la queue pour
les plus anciens vous rappelez tête on
faisait la queue à la poste
maintenant on fait en fait sur la queue
mais on a un écran plat et puis en
timbres soi-même son truc bon là on
pourrait faire ça mais si on fait ça et
qu'on est les premiers quand et où seule
la chimie française qui intégrerait ces
externalités carbone aux pollutions me
reste faire casser les reins par la
chimie au gaz de schiste américain par
la chimie gratuit grâce au gaz gratuit
du qatar ça ne marchera pas donc à ce
moment là il faut poser la question qui
fâche c'est à dire avec des relents fort
nauséabond je sais bien et la question
de comment se protéger on a décidé d'y
aller en transition sans attendre les
196 parce qu'ils tireront 196 on
n'arrive pas à se mettre d'accord
rendez-vous à la coop donc on peut aller
en transition il faut se protéger est
une question de la rampe
parce que en fait ce que vous dites là
vous avez des propos parfaitement
acceptable est compatible mais je pense
que dix ans auparavant
peut-être que vous aurait tenu des
propos durs gérant et ce qui m'intéresse
dans cette conversation c'est qu'on voit
bien qu'aujourd'hui on est arrivé à ce
point d'inflexion qui fait que
cette formidable civilisation fossiles
qui a généré tellement de croissance qui
a été d'ailleurs elle a été à la fois
aliénante et émancipatrice c'est pour ça
qu'on est dans cette ambiguïté parce
qu'elle a été au aussi à les yankees
merci patrice c'est à dire qu'on a eu
droit à des progrès extraordinaires dans
le domaine de la santé manquent
technologique mais aussi bien sûr dans
un état de dépendance tel qu'aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs avec des conséquences
géopolitiques on va pas en parler qui
nous reviennent en boomerang
donc on a du mal à sortir de ce modèle
là mais aujourd'hui peut-être que le
moment est venu
il ya maintenant de la part j'allais
dire de cette aristocratie fossiles il
ya peut-être maintenant plus à perdre à
maintenir la rente qu'à dire ok on lâche
et on y va et d'ailleurs votre discours
s'infléchit dans le gaz qui est bien sûr
la plus acceptable c'est une énergie bas
carbone allez carbonées faut quand même
le rappeler les synergies bas carbone et
quand vous parlez de sortir complètement
d'aller jusqu'au bout de la logique de
faire un rétropédalage dit oui on peut
retourner à modèle d'agriculture
familiale beaucoup plus intensive
on peut d mécanisée et bien j'ai pas
d'idée mécanisée parce que la dernière
chose que je des mécanismes s est bien
agriculture aux imams et des corbières
faire sortir de cette de sortir de cette
technologie qu'un peu superfétatoire on
voit bien que compte tenu de la
projection que l'on a c'est extrêmement
difficile d'y aller et donc il faudrait
aujourd'hui qu'il y ait vraiment un
passage très nette
ceux qui ont tenu la rampe pendant des
années décines d'y aller et qu'on arrive
cette articulation du mieux plutôt que
du plus on change tous deux modèles
économiques
et si possible ça sera pas se faire pour
des raisons altruistes ni éthique j'y
crois absolument pas mais ça pourra se
faire que si on a les industriels les
banquiers et la société civile
d'ailleurs qui a été la première à se
mobiliser
qui décide dans un pas de temps qu'il
venait de cinq à dix ans de faire le
grand saut
sinon s'il ya des forces qui résistent y
un ado qui propose des modèles
alternatifs et si le gouvernement enfin
les gouvernements restent complètement
immobile et tétanisé on va perdre un
temps pas possible parce que il ya quand
même un changement climatique est en
train de se faire sont pas oubliés donc
on va pas envoyer des fleurs pendant six
mois en attendant que les gens changent
lui se décide à faire le saut sachant
qu'il ya une dernière question que vous
posez vous avoir et chacun 1000 pour y
répondre c'est est-ce que raas et
d'énergie pour tout le monde parce qu'on
l'a dit on sera 9 milliards a priori en
2050 il y aura 2 milliard d'africains 3
milliard de chinois et d'indiens qui
tous voudrons consommer utilisé autant
d'énergie alors peut-être pas que les
américains mais mais mais que nous
probablement et est-ce qu'un aura assez
pour tout le monde est ce qu'on va pas
se battre comme dans mad max
mad max ça fait 30 ans qu'on va voir mad
max au cinéma et que mad max nous montre
un monde post énergétiques dans le monde
où il ya plus d'énergie
oui elle hic c'est qu'on a de moins
entendu la mi-journée dans les
négociations c'est à celle ci travaille
non travaillées tout ce mal est là pour
moi cette question et se pose pas
évidemment qu'il y aura assez d'énergie
à condition évidemment qu'on change la
façon dont on pense aujourd'hui c'est à
dire de croire que tout le monde aura
une voiture en 2050 que tout le monde
aura peut-être un frigo voire deux parce
que ya toujours des restes pour l'hiver
et c'était enfin c'est juste que la
conception du monde qu'on a aujourd'hui
elle ne fonctionnera clairement pas en
2050 est vrai c 'est pour lui dire pas
là il faut le dire mais c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui où la façon dont vous
conseillons c'est à dire tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui il faut le reproduire en
2050 et donc x nombre de personnes qu'on
sera ça ne marchera pas
en revanche la chose on n'a pas du tout
parlé pendant tout ce débat c'est le
fait qu'aujourd'hui on est déjà à
quasiment 1 degrés de réchauffement que
bientôt on va être sur trois degrés de
réchauffement parce que les états à la
façon dont ils se sont engagés
aujourd'hui ça nous place pas du tout
dans une trajectoire de réchauffement
qui est acceptable et en plus quand je
dis acceptable c'est politiquement
acceptable parce qu'à partir de 1 5° via
dezeen qui vont pas survivre et que même
avec moins d'un degré de réchauffement
on voit les impacts partout donc il ya
aussi cette question avant tout c'est à
dire que pour rester dans le budget
carbone qui nous est alloué si on veut
respecter nos objectifs de lutte contre
le changement climatique
on doit laisser 80% des énergies france
ils veulent ce fossile dans le sol
déjà on est très très loin de le faire
ensuite se pose la question d énergie de
transition mais à condition que ça reste
des énergies transition et le problème
du lobby gazier aujourd'hui c'est qu'il
n'a pas l'intention de le faire sur
peut-être dix ou vingt ans et de l'enfer
l'énergie pour le long terme le charbon
propre
tout ça c'est en train de prendre toute
la place toute notre espace mental au
lieu de penser à justement qu'est ce qui
vient après c'est à dire un mix
d'énergie renouvelable et de sobriété
énergétique et de juste réfléchir
différemment et aujourd'hui ça se voit
dans la négociation on freine la
transition on est en place plein de
fausses solutions nous parle de
biocarburants pas bon bref tout ça ça
m'énerve en fait ça me frustre quoi tu
me regardes mon allié alors pascal
canfin
moi je voudrais revenir sur la question
de l'emploi est cité une étude récente
de l'organisation internationale du
travail
ce qui est intéressant qu organisation
internationale du travail c'est que
c'est à parité entre les syndicats et
les employeurs ils ont sorti avant la
coop une étude qui montrent que la
transition énergétique mondiale qui
respecte les deux degrés donc exactement
ce dont on rêve tous et dont on a besoin
sacré dans le monde plus de 60 millions
d'emplois nettes c'est à dire que c'est
vrai que ça on détruit dans le pétrole
c'est vrai que ça on détruit dans le
charbon mais ça ancrée 60 millions de
plus ailleurs donc il n'y a aucune
raison d'opposer encore une fois l'oit
essais des syndicats plus les employeurs
et donc à part le lobbying intense vous
avez travaillé pour une entreprise mans
40 ans exxon qui a été qui est en train
d'être condamné par le procureur de new
york pour avoir caché les informations
dont il disposait sur le changement
climatique en trompant les consommateurs
et ses actionnaires
donc à part ce lobbying extrêmement
intense extrêmement riche et extrêmement
puissants de quelques compagnies qui ont
à perdre nous avons nous intérêt à cette
transition il ya en termes de qualité de
vie deere qu'on respire et d'emplois
créés la dernière phrase c'est une
citation de la patronne des syndicats
mondiaux c'est une australienne qui dit
il n'ya pas d'emplois sur une planète
nantes je crois que ça résume absolument
tout notre débat française du feu mais
je crois qu'on a une solution
on est tous d'accord c'est d'être une
taxe carbone c'est à dire pénalisés ce
qui polluent le plus ça c'est à notre
portée et je pense qu'on est tous
centrale
on me dit que la coupe 21 ne peut pas le
faire mais le problème que j'ai c'est
que si l'europe par exemple la france a
déjà démarré en une trajectoire carbone
si l'europe est la seule à avoir ça et
que les américains suivent pas je crois
que monsieur kerry a déjà déclaré que
répond d'engagement états unis parce que
ce lioret aucun engagement de la part du
congrès tout doit être approuvée par le
congrès si on n'a pas une convergence de
vue entre chine etats unis et europe on
est quand même d'une guerre économique
mondiale qu'on veuille ou pas je pense
pas qu'on va revenir de tourisme vert
faut qu'on fasse tourner des usines
c'est une condition pour limiter le
chômage
il ya un vrai problème de compétitivité
c'est ça mon souci ceci dit la solution
la moins modeste contribution du pétrole
c'est qu'on en a besoin on en consommera
moins en moins mettant une taxe carbone
pour chasser charbon aimé du gaz et
faisons un peu confiance aux ingénieurs
des nouvelles technologies et moi je
crois l'exemple du crottin de cheval je
le cite souvent la voiture est arrivée
je pense qu'on est loin de savoir ce
qu'ils faisaient
l'hydrogène le stockage d'électricité la
conjoncture ce qu'on parle la
technologie où on capturerait le co2 les
gens y travaillent
la destruction chimique du co2 par
exemple il ya des gens qui travaillent
c'est peut-être pas gratuit mais si on
mettait le paquet au lieu de se
précipiter à mettre des éoliennes
offshore
si on mettait beaucoup plus d'argent
dans la recherche tous les américains
les russes les chinois nous peut-être
qu'on trouverait on accélérerait les
processus de diversification
alors c'est vrai qu'en 1900 savais pas
qu'on allait éliminer crottin de cheval
des rues de paris re je vous propose de
regarder ce que pourrait devenir paris
en 2050 grâce à vincent callebaut qui va
venir nous rejoindre venez vous asseoir
vous vous écartez d'une place pour
laisser entrer vincent callebaut qui est
architecte qui est belge qui est jeune
et qui est le théoricien de l'archi
biotique 1 vous expliquerez ce que c'est
vous publiez paris 2050 les cité fertile
face aux enjeux du 21e siècle c'est la
mairie de paris qui vous a demandé de
dessiner la capitale dans 35 ans est
bien la voilà la capitale dans 35 ans va
commencer à regarder avec une première
image du centre de paris qui va nous
apparaître un moment certainement là
voilà c'est vous qui l'avez dessinée
vincent callebaut
alors expliquez nous ce qu'on voit et
alors c'est sévère c'est l'arrivée de la
campagne à paris mais pourquoi il ya
toute cette grande tour parce que a
priori les parisiens aiment pas beaucoup
les tours donc selon nous à paris 2005
ans et une vie qui aura utilisé comme
énergie et neurones pour finalement
réinventer notre modèle et assurer
véritablement ces transitions
énergétiques en construisant des tours
qui sont basées sur le concept de
solidarité énergétique
le fait de dire qu'aujourd'hui on est
capable à part
si des recherches scientifiques
actuelles de construire des bâtiments
qu'on appelle débit poste à dire des
bâtiments à énergie positive qui
produisent plus d'énergie qu'ils n'en
consomment que cette énergie soit
électrique calorifique et mam
alimentaire dans le cas des fermes
urbaines
on pourrait donc faire en sorte que ces
bâtiments redistribue en temps réel les
énergies qui produisent au tissu
haussmannien existants pour
véritablement devenir sobre en carbone
via les smart et là c'est la tour
montparnasse
ici c'est la tour montparnasse où
finalement aux éditions kid l'étalement
urbain à l'horizontale pour revenir un
étalement urbain à la verticale on
n'aura plus besoin de voiture quand on
n'a plus besoin de voiture ou consomment
moins de 60 si on arrive à vivre là où
on travaille on consomme moins
si on transforme la tour montparnasse
ont une fin verticale qui fait en sorte
que tous les déchets organiques non
comestibles des plantes soient
directement réinjectés dans une centrale
de biométhanisation par exemple le
déchet devient une ressource naturelle
recyclés recyclables
à la fin on aura moins besoin de se
déplacer pour cause puisqu'on habitera
et on travaillera à priori dans la même
tour c'est ça que vous imaginez et puis
surtout on aura nos maraîchers notre
nourriture dans cette même tour
également c'est exactement cela s'est
finalement l'innovation sociale basée
sur des nouveaux comportements urbains
où on vient se réapproprier l'air qu'on
respire on vient se réapproprier la
nourriture biologique produite
là c'est la rue de rivoli un conte voilà
exactement donc la rue de rivoli où on
propose de tripler la hauteur de
logements le long de cet axe de trois
kilomètres pour finalement résoudre la
crise chronique de manque de logement
dans paris et en même temps s'inscrire
dans le plan climat énergie de la ville
de paris qui vise à effectivement de
réduire de 75% des gaz à effet de serre
d'ici 35 ans alors regardons par exemple
la prochaine image c'est pas très loin
d'ici et d'ailleurs on voit le bâtiment
de tf1 on aurait pu voir le bâtiment de
france télévisions
c'est le pont au dessus de la seine
entre le 15e et le 16e arrondissement
on voit également des des bateaux
mouches qui commence à ressembler à des
jardins flottants
là c'est la motricité de l'eau que vous
utilisez donc le principe de la
solidarité énergétique c'est d'utiliser
les énergies qui sont sur place on sait
depuis einstein que tout mouvement toute
masse en mouvement produit de l'énergie
ici on pourrait donc transformer le
mouvement cinétique de la scène en
électricité grâce à des hydroliennes
introduite dans les piles de ce ponte
vecchio du futur et part notamment des
nombrils qui viennent transpercer les
tours dans laxe des vents dominants pour
intégrer des éoliennes multi pâle tous
les parisiens connaissent la petite
ceinture c'est la petite ceinture
autrefois il y avait un train qui
faisait le tour de paris aujourd'hui
sont des sondés soit des espèces vers
soi des endroits abandonné voilà on est
dans la petite ceinture
et qu'est ce qu'on a au dessus de soi
donc le long de la petite ceinture qu'on
voudrait transformer en une forêt
linéaire pour les énergies renouvelables
et pour les espaces d'agriculture
urbaine
on est venus intégrer des tours antilles
smockey c'est à dire des tours qui
viennent intégrer des nanotechnologies
qui permettent finalement que tous les
épidermes des bâtiments du futur vont
réagir exactement comme la feuille d'un
arbre c'est à dire fixer co2 qui est
dans l'air donc venir dépolluer l'air
urbain et en même temps venir produire
de l'oxygène et de l'énergie pour
ventiler les tunnels de la petite
ceinture et les éclairés grâce à de
l'électricité aujourd'hui quand on est
dans paris vous comparer ça à un îlot de
chaleur urbains
c'est la pierre évidemment là on aurait
moins chaud l'été peluche oliver dans
votre pari à vous c'est effectivement le
concept de la ville transpirante on veut
passer d'un pari gris un pari verdun
paris minérale un pari végétal d'un pari
imperméable à un pari perméable et avant
l'impact de la charnelle pourrait
finalement bio climatisé naturellement
grâce à l'évapotranspiration des plantes
l'atmosphère de paris ca sont ici un
prototype de fermes urbaines une ferme
urbaine qu'est ce que c'est ça a été
développé par le professeur dixon dépôt
des pommiers à la columbia university
depuis 20 ans c'est une tour qui vient
étages et des chants d'agriculture des
vergers communautaires et des potagers
individuels dans la ville pour claude
moine transports - transport de
marchandises étant donné que on consomme
ce qui est produit sur place plus dans
le bateau +12 route plus besoin de
camions plus besoin d'eux
d'avion pour transporter notre maïs
transgénique
une hlm de la porte des lilas encore
qu'on peut regarder tout de suite
annoncé basa ici c'est toujours cette
ferme urbaine où on a calculé que si on
mettait des fermes urbaines de 150
mètres à chaque porte de paris ont pour
dire on pourrait produire de
l'alimentation biologique pour la moitié
des parisiens images suivantes ça doit
être la porte des lilas la voix la porte
des lilas on a en fait proposé de ré à
billets les hbpm ces fameuses habitat
bon marché construit dans les années
1910 1920 qui sont de véritables
passoires thermiques c'était
l'apparition du béton armé par la
construction de ruches alvéolaire avec
des logements de toutes petites surfaces
de 9 mètres carrés qui sont construits
comme une alvéole qui est préfabriqués
standardisant on usines qui pourraient
accueillir des gens qui sont au rsa et
accueillir des étudiants et ses alcôves
peuvent venir s'imbriquent les unes dans
les autres pour avoir finalement un
système d'appartements collaboratif qui
peuvent s'étendre à un deux trois quatre
pièces et qui produit toujours dans ce
cas-ci l'énergie nécessaire pour que
cette hbm soit sobre en carbone alors
dernières images de ce paris 2005 en vue
par vincent callebaut la gare du nord
tout le monde l'aura que j'ai su réagir
wall inverse de la gare montparnasse
on ne veut pas venir la recouvrir d'une
dalle en béton pour la coupé du ciel ici
par exemple vous parliez de nouvelles
technologies on a travaillé avec les
cellules de graisse zèle qui sont
développés par le pfl à lausanne c'est
du verre qui met en place la technique
de l'électrolysé c'est à dire entre deux
feuilles de verre on vient mettre des
pigments végétaux pour faire en sorte
que c'est tour fonctionnent comme des
palétuviers inspiré des mangroves et en
façade nord sous la pluie on pourrait
produire une fois et demie plus
d'énergie qu'un panneaux photo
voltaïques d'aujourd'hui alors ce qui
est certain c'est que seule paris les
plus de bleu et il est plus vert que
celui que nous habitons pour l'instant
effectivement il est donc plus
intelligents ici toujours pour la gare
du nord la gare du nord c'est la
troisième plus grand gars mondial en
terme de trafic
avis donc ici ce qu'on propose c'est de
transformer les passes 750 mille
visiteurs qui traversent chaque jour les
32 quelle gare du nord en électricité
grâce à des dalles comme ici mais des
dalles piézoélectriques qui transforme
le mouvement ne vaut pas en énergie
des réactions pascal canfin c'est il ya
une entreprise je vais pas la citer ici
qui vient d'inventer la route électrique
vous vous dites en marchant on peut
aussi derrière on est connecté on peut
créer l'électricité mais allons-y alors
d'être d'accord avec tous les choix
architecturaux après les gouts et les
couleurs d'accord mais ce qu'on voit
c'est que si on est capable de faire
cette transformation intellectuelle en
pensant l'objectif final qui est de dire
zéro carbone émis on relocalise
l'alimentation ont reproduit sur place
mais en devant on a un défi
extraordinaire et tous nos ingénieurs
notre jeunesse nos entrepreneurs
ils sont là pour ça sollicitons les
mobilisons nous alors ce qui est
frappant avec vos travaux puisque vous
avez fait la conférence des têtes devant
vous on voit tout ça sur internet
ces images font beaucoup rêver les
jeunes générations alors est-ce qu'il
faut rêver nos invités geneviève ferone
eux
moi je suis assez fan parce que penser
la ville durable c'est quelque chose qui
m'enthousiasme j'ai alors je peux pas
m'empêcher en regardant certaines images
je veux dire est ce que vous fournissez
comme le prozac tu avec biodégradables
bien sûr le prozac parce qu'il ya un
côté quand même monde parfait qui est un
petit peu oppressant mais si non alors
ça c'est tout et je mets ça de côté je
serai dans l'hypothèse où il pourrait
faire tout ça et je me pose juste une
question qui est d'abord est ce qu'on
aura suffisamment d'énergie et de
matériaux mais sa tête jean marc enfin
on parlera pour arriver à cette utopie à
construire tout sera construire tous
évidemment et puis surtout je me dis est
ce qu'on aura suffisamment de maturité
dire une le gain de maturité qu'il faut
pour nous pauvres espèces alors on va se
faire on sera transformé en agent
énergétique veut dire qu'un peu comme
les hamsters on produira de
l'électricité absolument partout donc je
suis très partagé parce que je trouve ça
enthousiasmant parce que ça nous sort du
xixème siècle parce qu'on vit dans un
monde l' architecture de paris c'est le
19e siècle donc on épreuve projeter
comme ça dans le 22e siècle ça
parfaitement possible mais ça demande
plus de solidarité plus de coopération
plus de collaboratif et et je sais pas
comment vous faites vous mais déjà si
vous avez regardé comment fonctionne une
copropriété à paris
vous verrez callebaut moi je pense que
la maturité elle est là c'est tout le
but jusqu'au moins des conférences tedx
c'est aujourd'hui on n'arrête pas de
dire si dans les deux trois ans à venir
on change pas le climat
notre système va dans le mur donc c'est
pas du 22e siècle
car ce type de projet on les construit
aujourd'hui à taïwan au caire en menant
vers a égaré qui est en train d'être
construite par vous alliez au monde et
qui vont pas attendre le 22ème siècle
pour construire ce type de bâtiment
intelligent
jean marc jancovici est ce que c'est
réalisable de près vous je pense que non
j'aime bien jean c'est sympa moi j'adore
le vert donc je trouve ça vraiment très
sympa moi je rêve de mettre des heures
partout et des plantes partout tels que
les voitures etc
après savoir si c'est réalisable il faut
faire un truc qui est monstrueusement
qui dit manquer de faire des calculs les
électeurs on les attendait est ce que
vous avez fait des calculs sur l'énergie
de fabrication des matériaux oui donc en
fait on a travaillé avec le groupe
d'ingénieurs setec basé à paris je
compte continuer la question est ce que
vous avez fait des calculs sur la
disponibilité en matériaux autour de
paris pour trouver les matériaux qui
vont bien est ce que vous avez fait les
calculs pour que ce soit pas juste paris
qui en profitent mais aussi lyon
toulouse etc et en quand on fait ce
genre de règle de trois on se rend
compte que très vite on tombe sur des
choses qui seront peut-être résolu un
jour mais qui aujourd'hui sont des
problèmes qui sont pas si simple que ça
a trouvé par ailleurs nous les français
on adore parler technique tant qu'on
adore se mettre sur la gueule entre les
gens qui aiment le nucléaire les genres
etc
or l'essentiel des problèmes dans la
transition sont les preuves non
technique celebrate culturel c'est le
rapport à la limite est un problème
culturel
je veux dire toute la civilisation
humaine a été basée sur la transgression
de la limite on adore les gens qui sont
allés se balader sur la lune et qui sont
montés sur l'everest si ça c'est pas de
la transition de la limite je sais pas
ce que c'est donc on adore transgresser
la limite et là on dit face au défi
écologique en cours soit sage et qu'on
accepte des limites c'est compliqué et
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué que chara
technique on va avoir besoin de changer
l'économie je le disais tout à l'heure
évidemment qu'on peut donner un job à
tout le monde
aucun problème le problème c'est de les
payer autant qu'aujourd'hui ça on sera
pas faire d' oncle mais on de on devrait
le faire
mais sauf que pas en les payant comme
aujourd'hui parce que sa boucle pas les
règles de trois donc est ce assez
un problème technique non plus donc ce
qui la vraie révolution à faire dans
cette histoire à mon avis elle est moins
de technique parce que je suis assez
confiant sur le fait que techniquement
canton quand on se triture à pau les
neurones on trouve des tas de machins
qu'on n'aurait pas trouvé si on n'avait
pas cherché je suis très optimiste de ce
point de vue c'est d'être sûr que parce
qu'on va pas avoir trois fois une chance
d'accord on n'a pas deux extra balle et
on en tire une fois été il faut que ça
tente juste du premier coup c'est de pas
se tromper sur le potentiel de ce qu'on
va faire compte tenu de la vitesse à
laquelle ça peut se déployer des
barrières culturelles qu'il faut
franchir du fait qu'on est en train de
parler d'un problème mondial et tout le
monde n'a pas la culture française ne
regarde pas un français que déjà il ya
25 soldats indiens etc
donc c'est ça le vrai sujet et là dessus
je trouve qu'en france on est très sous
investis c'est à dire qu'on pense
beaucoup de technique qui compense pas
du tout modèle économique culturel etc
de manière un peu pragmatique à
l'anglais alors réponse de vincent
callebaut et puis on va regarder aussi
vos autres projets pour new york pour
haïti mais rappeur est donc
effectivement derrière les belles images
du projet de paris il ya le groupe setec
bâtiment qui ont calculé le différentiel
entre ce que c'est tour produisait
combien énergie est ce que c'est tour et
en quoi les habitants fin quelle
quantité d'énergie les habitants et
consommer et donc ils ont prouvé qu'à
minima c'est tour était autosuffisant il
a très bien ce genre de la mairie cus
cima partiellement alors leader de 158
ma carrière et je cherchais ma carrière
à mal des monstres vous plaît aussi
aujourd'hui avec les certifications leed
boïm thq eux on est obligés d'étudier ce
qu'on appelle le carbone un train
s'extasier par exemple tout carbone qui
est rejeté durant la construction des
matières premières et donc tout cela
nous la nouvelle génération on a appris
à calculer tout ça et on le fait dans
les bâtiments qui sont chantier journée
et je voudrais qu'on voit la tour qui
est en train d'être
construit à taïwan je veux dire un mot
sur ce point haïti on parlait d'un
nouveau modèle économique effectivement
aujourd'hui haïti on développe un projet
de village anti sismiques qui offre des
jardins nourriciers à chaque habitant
est ce type de projet il peut être aussi
nourrie par un système de croo food inc
ou quand on a un grand tremblement de
terre comme par exemple au népal au lieu
de donner votre argent n'importe où par
sms ou sur facebook vous pouvez
sponsoriser des projets et donc nous les
consommateurs de la ville on peut aussi
devenir acteur et fédérer des projets à
l'étranger
donc là je me souviens plus mais
avançons à taïwan de qu'on voit ici
depuis un balcon c'est une tour
exactement comment elle est destinée à
paris qui est en chantier depuis quatre
ans qui sera livré à la fin de l'année
prochaine c'est une tour qui est
certifié leed gold plus l'une des dunes
des plus hautes certifications
environnementales américaines qui
économise l'émission de 150 tonnes de
co2 par an et qui sera recouverte de
plus de 25 mars à 25 mille arbres et
arbustes 10-q qui vint finalement
rapatrié on va la voir on va la voir de
l'extérieur ce serait peut-être mieux
voilà mon dieu et donc c'est une tour
torsadé qui vient également intégrer des
règles de bon sens comme par exemple le
fait de venir assurer une ventilation et
un éclairage naturel
dans tout les cas jusqu'à lier les cages
d'ascenseur et dans tous les étages de
parkings française du ce1 mots oui moi
je suis comme monsieur j'aime beaucoup
le vert c'est très séduisant mais je me
pose je suis pragmatique donc le poste
de questions j'ai pas envie de vivre
dans neuf mètres carrés deuxièmement
c'est comme la transition énergétique
dans ce pays la loi qui vient de passer
combien ça coûte et comme enjeu le
finance parce que ça doit coûter très
cher
philippe bihouix alors si j'étais gentil
je dirais que je trouve ça vraiment très
jolie moi aussi et si on aime rêver ya
aussi star wars set je crois qu'à du
sentier auquel à sortir dans pas
longtemps
et si j'étais méchant je suis ingénieur
aussi donc je dirais qu'il ya pire qu'un
ingénieur qui reste c'est un architecte
qui rêvent pas cessé c'est effrayant
mais absolument effrayant parce qu'en
fait la consommation de matériaux fayat
pas le cuivre le titane pour les
feuilles de palétuviers aux
nanotechnologies et tout ce qu'on veut
pour pour faire tout ça peut-être à
l'échelle parisé dans vie dans le reste
de la planète mais sûrement pas pour
faire ça partout avec une humanité
complètement
ultra urbanisées parce qu en fait
derrière tout ça ça consommerait faire
c'est déjà le cas aujourd'hui dans paris
et que les deux millions de personnes a
l'impression qu'on occupe à beaucoup
placement fait si parce qu'il ya partout
des dépôts des centres logistiques des
trucs tout autour en consomment de la
consomment de la douala de la terre en
artificialisés aujourd'hui l'équivalent
d'un département français
tous les sept ans en france et le rythme
dans laquelle on transforme étaient les
meilleures terres agricoles en truck
bitume et voilà donc ce truc là c'est
pas possible tu ne peux pas fonctionner
sur les flux logistiques même si on
habite dans son container et qu'on y vit
aussi alors dernier beau gosse à cannes
c'est que justement les flux logistiques
on a tendance à les baisser
aujourd'hui les ingénieurs aussi y
développe des nouveaux matériaux qui
sont des choix des matériaux composites
soit des matériaux construit à partir de
déchets nous actuellement en
développement sur un projet sur les
océans qui viendraient recycler les
déchets du 7e continent en argot plast
donc c'est à dire un plastique recyclé
qui se mélangent à des algues mais pas
venir également à trouver pour faire
cette quantité là mais si aujourd'hui
c'est possible de trouver justement
c'est circularité dont vous parliez pour
faire en sorte de trouver un système
solidaire on a toujours joué dans le
passé comme on a toujours trouvé dans le
passé d'ailleurs pourquoi on est passé
en est on a répondu à la pénurie c'est
pour ça qu'on est passé du renouvelable
non renouvelables a toujours trouvé dans
le passé et donc on trouvera toujours
dans le futur teorem 2010 sauf que nous
sommes en train de le réaliser
dernier mot alix mazouni je trouve ça
très beau et plein de gens rêvent et je
pense que c'est important que notre
génération est celle qui vient commence
vraiment à devenir créatifs parce qu'on
va vraiment avoir besoin après il ya
plein de choses qu'on peut faire dans
les prochaines années sans attendre ces
magnifiques bâtiments que ce soit arrêté
de financer la pollution que ce soit
arrêter de construire des aéroports
climaticides déroute climaticides plutôt
que de développer les transports en
commun puisque a pas que la voiture dans
la vie aussi tout un ensemble un
attirail de possibilités pour créer une
mobilité différentes que ce soit
d'investir dans les énergies
renouvelables et surtout d'aider les
pays les plus pauvres
il compte déjà face aux impacts du
changement climatique à quelles que
soient les discussions pour puisse avoir
ici donc tout ça va ensemble en fait
c'est à dire qu'il n'ya pas une solution
miracle et un attirail de choses qu'on
peut mettre en place en commençant
aujourd'hui seulement à paris en france
ce qui est certain c'est qu'en 2050 on
verra vraisemblement cette émission et
irrigue le rond
1 je vous remercie d'avoir participé une
pensée pour lui bondi metteur en scène
de théâtre qui nous a quittés le
week-end dernier
évidemment il était venu dans ce soir ou
jamais avait claude régy d'ailleurs vous
allez on retrouve on retrouve lui bondi
il ya une différence puisqu'il est écrit
des pauses et écrit des silences et les
silences je trouve fantastique les
pauses c'est très relatif
ce que la pause c'est une respiration ou
quelqu'un prend le temps de dire une
chose le grand problème aujourd'hui au
théâtre c'est que souvent les acteurs
font des pauses avant de dire quelque
chose et ça j'aime pas moi je préfère
que je dépose interviennent mais j'ai
pas que quelqu'un prépare dans la pause
quelque chose quand on sent que
quelqu'un joue quelque chose avant de
jouer quelque chose je suis impatient
mais par contre quand quelqu'un a dit
quelque chose où pendant qu'il dit
quelque chose on peut s'arrêter de
parler pendant qu'on dit quelque chose
et il ya une pause qui intervient ça
c'est possible mais avant de dire
quelque chose de faire des pauses ou
d'écouter l'autre est de faire de jouer
l' écoute moi je veux pas qu'on joue les
couteaux on écoute on n'écoute pas où on
est tout à la fois monomane ou bien
comme unique mais on ne peut pas faire
semblant par la pose de faire quelque
chose voilà c'était lui bondi dans ce
soir ou jamais je vous remercie tous les
sept d'avoir participé à cette émission
et on se quitte évidemment en musique
avec dominique à qui va nous interpréter
sera bientôt en concert au théâtre du
châtelet et qui va nous interpréter
central otago un extrait de son dernier
disque dominique à qui a l'air d'avoir
un petit problème
y'a pas de problème de vie